[Music]
i love that sound that they are
different it's a different type of
marching band
muay thai right i get it
is an 11 piece techno brass band from
germany playing tonight in las vegas
it's sold out i'll tell you that right
now but you might still be able to find
some tickets online we'll talk about
that in a second but we want to welcome
the members of the band let me see if i
can get it right the very first time we
have hold on don't tell me sebastian
sebastian hans thomas adrian nailed it
all right thank you guys for being here
and they're funny on top of everything
else i like these guys um where did you
come up with this concept
thomas it was just the idea to do
something unique what didn't exist
before and um yeah we thought that brass
instruments and techno fit together well
it sounds amazing and people love it
obviously you're sold out tonight adrian
is this true everywhere you go
yeah mostly yeah
not a bad problem to have right
so how long ago are you said it's about
four years no six
six years
six and a half
how did it come together and has it been
the same you have 11 members the four of
you here today has it been the same
group the whole time you switched out a
few
yeah we are basically the same group
from the beginning yeah the thomas
gathered together from various
parts of hamburg and the music scene
disciplined people you were the
coordinator you were the guy i put this
all together and you're based in germany
yes in hamburg okay so
you're excited because now you're out
and about again right uh during the
pandemic i guess you didn't do too many
uh gigs yes that was a tough time yeah
and now we're glad to
play again so where else are you going
to be in the i know you're in las vegas
tonight uh where else are you guys going
we're going to coachella festival
tomorrow oh fun yeah and then we're
having a gig in
los angeles in between
and then again coachella and phoenix and
phoenix nice so staying in this region
before we had a very long tour across
the states that's great well we're so
happy you're here i hope you have a
great time while you're in las vegas and
coachella and everywhere else thank you
for being here today guys let's tell you
where you can find them tonight moyta is
at brooklyn bowl okay but the problem is
they're sold out but
you can still go online and check out
tickets brooklynbold.com uh you never
know maybe you'll luck out j.c let's go
check in with him